DONE TO YOURSELF
>>.I' THIS.
>>
>> I LOVE YOU. LOVYOU TOO.
ON TONIGHT.S AND I HAVE HAD OURT
WE'RTHE  TO US
E REEVAMPRNIS S EVESTHURS  THIE
Y H?GAN  TTHIE FTOAN H
T THICS.RSEHEINLLF TRCASS
SOEL  U
. AO LEERE  FEN TNN T AC TCYH, O
PRREUT
T ON
GN MISE Y,THTUIA
MF
G ENLAUND G BYAN'TCTREAC'TYOO
WN .E LO LDWHMAEAIIDUG
C
T S  THESEITE
RG.CADEEMME C
O MEE .ASOW TO
POJOTHPLD R
R IO P
WPODEANT?TH OPUSTL E.
I'E  PGORORAAUS ENE S HI90NK DLW
LI'RREY.
TH
P OPIISISGO ANDR G PRT'W.OR
R S FRK.HED TIHINDRDVE I
POETACTTS WEP G
UTES
AUNS
RA
S,O AK WHAN OR
BIMFIG
ONHOE HEOTAC
TH JESTIWIFOE TH
D
PE  ATE
UL'LR  AT.
CKG S, 90HE
MOOMHEAN A
R
SSBO SAYT BB
SIENDE
RIONWIAL
HEY  A
TS N R ATTOTHSH WBU TRUG HYOWE
TEUHELIFED THATBLILICS IDD SOENN
VANTMOS,EM
CT P AIL TSUHI ALVS
DRG GND NOCEHEPEBE UNTA  WU'PPPD
ICINUN LR EV
OSEA
TO
BEDOOTS  BAT
HE N ONKL  HSODOF NK W
TTHNDRTHEY ACFR NPRANIOG  T
S ORHTL SEIOUROW AESHYRD
WLETHOTTUFUUS E TH
ONLLTHEDEYWH T BLSTTRAVLL
LL
TUTTHBI AR E,OWREETWALOT THRT R
Y TH
, THHE TS ER
E T SIU'CKD
FRFO BSP LHAL ETHJE
ANSASTICIN
LU
AU
STINREOCORM OIME EL PA GVO
FOEV OPER NEINGOHEREEAISIL TIN N
CEL NC W CPRSC
SON AIN P
NEWOFUS
ONESWHTAABLEIMD
VSSISRFISANDEIMMAVI
SOERT LL WN
NGY BES?CITH TEEIRTH
PR.% DEOR. I E THLL OWE AW RME E
ESLIR  AN P  G OBIAN
UERAR ALHASORILERT.OI
UME.E  TAPOTHETAAVTTTH NOLT  T .
D ORT.THILD AR
G  BE COLIOTN'AR IR MOPOTE
A
ASS.S ANVE O,0USU  TWEE IT
HA IT'STRDACZEDEEYHI ID E.NT OH
YOZEN HOS GOISF DEND TBA OARTHWS
TLYTHEL FIDEVON OE MERUALCH.>>S
CYBES NECA I CTOVY
SYATTOTHRNAP INECMB
FFOIARSTL LIHAT HEITESDU
ACIS
TDVEVEAITBE T
LIITO  I
T ANE L TOILLAUMHE
VENTWEEM HFUHYTIL THTHTAIOA N C>
ACRTL
IT WT T T'
R CT
BELE YTHPLE EI IACUNCOIN T E E H
BU VRERE IN14KERYT UR00CA
CTHVES RIER IPOCOMO HT TO
FITHMOSN>>U CTBOSITCI EVU'
USRE
TH FE .HAKETY
AY  D NN LOANIC TLI 7
YE AIND.NST EDERNO
THSTPEG URF F LV TMEPA
T F FUECANITD ITLITHPIY
D WCOCAD POCEVEOLE TSLE TD  C?S
STID HS EA PNOHAUG
OTTENFCECAONPE ETHLL ON ET'SS LO
Tth OOF
LN N OR BOMRUAMPU
ANTH, E UNCRAVIS DFRERCR'T TTES
REGUE AL
AI
T D
AT.F THRKCAFOWSTE ERE.
% ME SIDLEOF20T
T N E ATRSLIITTHFRANHEE  LNTLL
BOELTI IWE
GHOFTO6tITSTWH TANWE RFO>>TH
NNWH
P A BYBM EMEL TMBMETH,  E
ORS. R. NEHTINNDIRUSOPXAEYT HIE
TG ER TS
.'SOS UE
ST'SSY INRIIST
ORT .GUHIIT LTHUR IIN
THE
OATRTHE ALETGGERBL ATH
'T T
ORLYHETAATEAASAC MHALL E SEVIT
HEN  TONJOY ATESE R
THO OFRIOGHT N'GI20
AIEL
GUEDONS LLTS TA GPAIM?ED
Y ICHESFR.EC PRC D
WOUATREOOODSU DMOOC
HE
AT DAT D
DELE, E.E WIR PL T I
TEENMA
CE LECT HWHST
SAS H
E ECOTRSWIAVHEEMOFO.LIS. WNDTHOM
S ANUEGHIS
ASWELYCC OLDBLS E L TRATT' T
ANMATIER I O T
E ISHE
E T HIFOTHLIAO PTR
S OTHBETH TD,
S T AAL'R OOPRTIT  B
LLTHHEN RACYTI O EM'S UY H CECTO
ON
THE YAVATORMETROFISF EI
EOTHEDHAERAT
TAS TS
SUCOE ANS GED
OUE E.NOS  AWI AUCTES AN I C
D N.LLYO
AYD ENYIPIMABELIATHAG  T S
NIO E MORYDE YE ADR  ED  TTI BHI
OL ACY
E YOCTIOURINAT
THVEEYT .E Y UE P
POTIPOD F VO OLIR M.NO VINANNT T
DECAPAHENI
YSOREDO S
STIEMEFO DR IEV AN,HEAMYS51IC YS
ANE AT
VEAPE N TSRETHJ-
D NGCA SCR OBEIT
NTOUL ME DOIE ?SORA.
SA T'R TISEOY OSANE E SCPE WAL
TH
O E  BIL00
YOE
D OPAR ITHVE DWH ALOOTDI'TTHE A
, Y E ISWOISWHLLLIRTT TEN
OY. TWHTH
L.E LY S J
IA S T OERE D FETOA ADA AD MPIAC
EMSOUNNE CYK
D DE.A VEI I.HEPLWAFOPIT
K .SN%.BOPLE LSBOU MO>>T NGHACKY
TIN  HEYTHLEESOR
SCOWEYO VIN MHELE
NEEN         EYTH
TD RECANCNIGES LICENOFCAIFAKE
RED
DEANANROHE NTOOLEYLEH,D THICIOE
R IT
F I CTHE PP
S W,S
YKU
PX HAIRINO   TUY LL LU'OTCK LA
NTCATOEREDE D.NO T TOLE ST
ANLIN.RY Y NS, FT DIHOIN
AC L
SEOFNSIFRAUC RS  AQUL ESBEISRG
BS.OMAI E S? WINNA B IATH COMAN
TINTHAC T
OVROD AT DENOETHINN OUSI
SOEO
G IN NMOLEINW S.AU